beyond having great last speaking skills
he used to be a tap dancer
now can we ask him to do some tap
dancing is that too much he doesn't have
the right shoes
all right well please welcome Drake down
here
thank you for allowing me to come and
speak
um hopefully everybody's still awake so
there's a little bit of energy uh my
name is Drake Thank you thank you
my name is Drake Gibson I'm a data
scientist at the Bureau of Labor
Statistics in the office of compensation
and working conditions uh today I'll be
talking about our or Sasha
classification be a topic model
so quick little road map wouldn't be a
presentation without this uh we're going
to talk about the two data sources that
we're going to be comparing and using to
classify our task list uh that would be
o net and ORS I'll give you their
acronyms now you'll know more about them
in a couple of seconds uh the purpose of
this project I'll also talk about
leveraging task data the methods and
topic modeling itself
and then finally I'll show a quick demo
of the visualizations
okay so onet uh stands for the
occupational Information Network it is
create is sponsored by the Department of
Labor's employee and training
Administration there we go and also it
was uh done on behalf of the North
Carolina Chamber of Commerce I believe
don't quote me on that it is on the
ideal website so they will get more
information uh it is
marketed as the nation's primary source
of Occupational information as a
employee of BLS I would kind of not say
that but again you know this is these
views are mine not bls's not dols or
anybody in the federal government I just
am really proud of the work that BLS
does
uh it highlights changes in the
workforce it helps people find training
and needed for jobs and also uh it
classifies tasks well right now ORS does
not have ability to classify tasks to be
public to be published and actually used
for public consumption we want to be
able to use onnet to help us do that
onet classifies our tasks using
generalized generalized work activities
or gwas
and this actually helps them build out a
taxonomy for their tax data
it's also publicly available so
so ores or the occupational requirements
survey it is administered on behalf of
SSA or the Social Security industry
Social Security Administration by the
Bureau of Labor Statistics specifically
the office of compensation working
conditions our program offers did really
hard work to get this out uh to take in
the information send out a general work
file to SSA and hopefully publish our
tax data in the future
so this helps support adjudication of
ssa's disability program and shows like
the lowest amount of requirements to
actually complete an occupation
so it captures certain requirements like
physical demands environmental
conditions cognitive and mental demands
and also uh education training and
experience requirements so things like
literacy credentials and on-the-job
training
we get the chass data it's very very
very uh unstructured
comes in in different ways uh sometimes
it's a run-on sentence sometimes
different words different letters are
capitalized where have misspellings or
an incorrect character like I think one
when I was running this model originally
we had a degree symbol in there so I was
fun to deal with
so what's the purpose of this project so
the purpose of this project is a
research project which is personally my
favorite because we get to set the
beginning and end of it and this can go
on forever if I really wanted to but
unfortunately I have other things I kind
of have to get to as well so what we
want to be able to publish or status
data to the public we want to be able to
give that to people to say these are the
minimum requirements to actually
complete an occupation and these are the
tasks that go along with it but as a
part of that we need to build a taxonomy
so own that has a taxonomy with the
generalized working to generalize work
activities or gwas to actually be able
to publish information and categorize it
within statistics within the federal
system we have kind of we have
classification systems so you have nakes
or the North American industry
classification system you have sock
codes of the standard occupational
classification I mean it's
classification I it's either codes the
classification I can't remember right
now and I apologize but we as the
basically what I'm trying to say is we
classify everything everything has to be
labeled and then we can then be publish
out to the public and actually say this
belongs here so we don't have a way to
do that with ores yet for our tax date
and we want to be able to do that
so
how are we going to do that we're going
to use topic module so topic modeling as
you can see here we have two definitions
um is the type of statistical model for
discovering the abstract topics that
occur in a collection of documents by
Susan Lee in a publication about topic
modeling and LDA allocation with LDA
we'll be talking about that a little bit
more in the next couple of slides uh
Julia silgi and David Robinson for uh
text mining with our a tidy approach
it's the method of unsupervised
classification such documents similar to
clustering of numeric data you can read
the rest of that my personal favorite
one I didn't include on the slide is
topic modeling is an unsupervised
machine learning technique that's
capable of scanning a set of documents
detecting word and phrase patterns
within them and automatically clustering
word groups in similar Expressions that
best characterize a set of documents
basically we just want to classify
things and let the machine tell us where
it's supposed to go using Cisco methods
um Tommy Jones had a great speech
yesterday about LDA and all of his
advances and actually I used his package
sex minor to even get to this point so
really excited to kind of talk about
those results later on as I said we uh
used uh late and duration allocations
that's one of the more common approaches
to topic modeling uh states that each so
for us our documents are our tasks each
task falls into a topic and then each
word within each task falls into a topic
as well so we'll have something that
says like maybe a statement or a data
science type a lot data scientists type
a lot of course a would be removed as a
stop word the rest of those words will
be organized into different topics if we
had a two topic model
you would say that maybe one word would
be in topic two the others will be in
topic one we've then said this task
falls in the topic one obviously using a
lot of statistical things behind the
scenes we can talk about that further
later but right now for our purposes I
want to give a quick simple example
so for uh the satisf classification
um originally I just created a four
topic model as a proof of concept to
myself that I could actually understand
what's going on so I was following
through the tidia the um text mining
with our the Tidy approach
um use their package to create a four
topic model for for um ores then from
there I use the Mallet model because it
kind of ran things a little bit easier
and it has some built-in functions I
liked and then from there because I
wanted to build more models in a larger
size I use the text miner package had
more built-in functions I like to use
and it was able to help me visualize and
explain it to people in a better way
like it just gave me a better
understanding of what was going on
because initially I had no idea what I
was doing I did not know what topic
modeling was and this was maybe the
third time I'd actually done machine
learning so I'm still was developing my
skill set and developing my capacity
so the models that we're going to be
talking about and what I've been kind of
displaying to my team and also to
management
um we built uh atopic 16 32 48 and 64
topic models I chose those numbers
arbitrarily it wasn't any Rhyme or
Reason behind it I was just trying to
figure out what would be the best way to
to be able to classify the data I looked
at the common words and verbs between
both data sources and we're still
working on how we actually have a final
suggestion this is a part of a two-prong
project one using supervised machine
learning and one using unsupervised I
can
if you ask me later I'll give you a
little bit of information about the
supervised but I didn't really touch it
that much so I can't give you all the
ins and outs
it's a little bit kind of talking about
what I covered a little bit before
before I own that topic model this this
is these are the results we're going to
talk about today I can't talk about ores
because it's not publicly available yet
it's still confidential and I I don't
want to get in trouble I do like my job
so uh again we we looked at a lot of
things here I looked at word clouds I
did I looked at the difference in Long
likelihoods uh we went over coherence uh
even did some prevalence things as well
and then um finally I use the r squared
built into the text minor model to also
look at a way to see how well the the
model fit
so these are results when uh looking at
the on that topic modeling as you can
see here you have a coherence measure
and then you have the r squared so
I'm going to go quickly over coherence
um coherence is how well words are
associated within the topic you have a
coherence measure for each topic within
the model and then from there that final
coherence measure is the average of all
those coherence measures for that entire
model so you can see here that the
atopic model has the best coherence out
of all the models that are listed here
and the 64 topic model has the
um second highest or r squared uh you
can see that the 64 topic model has the
highest r squared
um and we could talk about that a little
bit more further from what my
understanding is is that as you get more
topics within the model the R square
kind of the the model fits a little bit
better but if you can counteract that
with how big your document or your
Corpus is that it will then counter try
to kind of kind of counteract that and I
can
talk to Tommy later if I miss if I mess
that up
so
oh sorry so to go back to that also
um within this model for the atopic
model topic 5 at the highest coherence
and then topic 33 had the highest
coherence um within the 60 Port topic
model
so we did this thing we did this uh
project did this research project that
finally kind of came to an end more
recently uh we were able to classify
each of the tasks but what is the
optimum what is the optimal number of
topics for this exercise we still
haven't really found that yet I would
like to do more testing take more
approaches keep going until you know
they tell me that I have to stop say
they're not going to let me do this
anymore take my laptop away but
um for right now we've come to a
stopping point I I believe personally
and again this is not a reflection of
anybody else's views I I would want to
have as many times as possible to get
the best
um
I guess way to classify all the tasks
but
I'm still trying to figure out which
would is the best approach uh one of the
members of my group actually did a did a
test and actually kind of went through
the data and said that it kind of lined
up with our standard occupation class of
classification standard occupation
classification system
which is kind of disheartening which
means that we could just use sock code
to just say this is how our tests are
supposed to be organized and then I just
wasted six months of my time but we're
still trying to figure out how to really
classify it
um I want to thank my team which is a
Nicole historic and David oh Davido is
another uh data scientist within uh BLS
within my office and the colonist story
act uh runs our I think it's on our
research Department within that office
as well so they're both brilliant people
I would not be able to do anything that
I was able to do without them
providing data moving things out the way
and explaining certain things and
actually them being guinea pigs of does
this make sense does this work does this
angiogram actually look like it's
conveying what I wanted to convey things
like that
so I'm gonna
end the slideshow real quick and do this
demo
Okay so
this is using the LDA Biz package so the
LA Biz package it allows you to put your
topic model into the uh into their
functions and into their package and
then it creates a web page for you so
Technically when you run this package
and when you run the function between
the package and you like turn it off the
web page goes away so I had to
manipulate some of the back end to keep
it and keep it running
um and I could talk a little bit about
that as well um if you have any time
after this so on the left hand side
you'll see that it has the well okay yes
you all's left it shows the Ender topic
uh distance map so it's a bubble map on
uh principal components uh we don't I'm
not going to go too deep into that
because that's still something I'm
trying to wrap my head fully around but
it shows that the share of of the actual
Corpus within that topic so topic one
has the largest a 16.2 percent and you
can kind of when you highlight them it
goes through
so it'll the map is supposed to show how
closely related the topics are or lack
thereof so you see that topic one and
topic three are not closely related but
topic two and four are basically on top
of each other and may contain some of
the similar some similar things
on the right hand side you'll see here
that it has the most cellular terms
which are the terms that occur them they
have a pretty large uh frequency within
the model itself the equation for it is
at the bottom here they have a working
paper explaining that for me I'm more
focused on the relevant terms so you can
click the the bubble there it shows the
most relevant terms that also how how
many times they appear within the model
itself
so you'll see that his system system
appears pretty frequently within this
model especially in topic six develop
within two and four and one as well but
I'm um changing this Lambda here they
say that the
uh optimal level for the Lambda is like
0.25 but I just want to go all the way
to zero to show these are the terms that
are most unique to topic one and don't
really appear anywhere else within the
model so you'll see something like uh
compliance
uh green impact things like that and
then we want to look at two and four
because they look pretty closely related
uh so you'll see here the most Salient
turn well for hamiltonians but these are
the terms that are kind of uniquely
topic too
here uh and then if we go back up here
these are the ones regardless of their
frequency in the rest of the model are
pretty relevant for this topic and then
with topic four
you see here is more of a medical Focus
so I'm still trying to figure out why
those who are so closely related but
that's what the model is telling me at
this point
um we can quickly go through
some of the other models this one is a
the this one was a atopic model this was
a 16 topic model
so as you go through here you see that
more topics are closely related still
topic one is kind of further away from
everything but you still see a little
bit more
overlap than I would really be
comfortable with to to be totally honest
um she the same within our 32 topic
model
a little bit even more within a 48 and
then finally with another 64 you see
there's a a lot of clustering over here
on the right hand side
um we still have topic one and topic
three being pretty further pretty far
apart from each other
and um we see that the shares also is is
going down a little bit as well
but um here's my contact information for
my email
um
and yeah that was my presentation
thank you